[Music]
today we provide you once again with the
most important news about your upcoming
favorite movies and Series this week we
cover the Marvel's Aquaman and the lost
kingdom an HBO series by Steven
Spielberg and news about the upcoming
Hellboy reboot plus there's updates on
Venom 3 and the latest rumors regarding
the potential new leader of the Avengers
have fun watching
Aquaman and the lost kingdom will be the
last film from the current dceu to be
released at the end of the year that
will make a total of 16 films in the
universe that started with Man of Steel
in 2013. one thing is certain the
previous universe will no longer be
continued after the acquisition of the
DC Studios by James Gunn and Peter
Safran and will instead be replaced by
the new DC Universe or DCU for short
thus all movies that have been released
after 2013 will no longer receive a
sequel which also means the exit from DC
for most of the leading actors with
Aquaman and the lost kingdom the nearly
10-year existence of the old Universe
could be brought to a grand conclusion
the same time create a good transition
to the DCU however the latest reports
suggest that the movie is far from being
well received by audiences Movie Insider
Jeff Snyder who is usually well informed
recently commented on Twitter about the
test screenings of the Aquaman sequel he
claims to have learned that these have
just started and so far have turned out
to be extremely disappointing lead actor
Jason Momoa is also rumored to have
reacted with considerable resentment
when he learned that viewers were
leaving the screenings in droves this is
probably also a result of the fact that
initial screenings were already run last
summer which were likewise received
negatively the 43 year old could
nevertheless stay with the DCU unlike
most of his fellow Stars rumors have
been circulating for some time that
although he will turn his back on
Aquaman in the future he will take on
the role of the alien Bounty Hunter Lobo
the DC bosses have not yet officially
spoken about this for now the priority
will be on Aquaman and the lost kingdom
and the remaining DC EU films therefore
the film may not be doomed yet there is
still plenty of time to turn things
around in post-production and deliver a
worthy sequel to the very successful
first installment the test screenings
are not a reliable indicator for the
success of a film anyway in the past
many films flop there which were then
successfully adjusted based on the
feedback before they flopped at the box
office despite excellent test screenings
either way we are looking forward to the
final outcome Aquaman and the lost
kingdom is slated for a December 25th
2023 theatrical release
while Guillermo del Toro's comic book
adaptations Hellboy and Hellboy 2 the
Golden Army with Ron Perlman are modern
Classics
2019's Hellboy with David Harbor was a
total flop both at the box office and
among critics nevertheless the franchise
is to continue as a new movie has now
been announced according to an exclusive
report from discussing film rights
holder Millennium Media is giving it
another try with a live-action Hellboy
movie The Script has already been
written as it is to be directed by Brian
Taylor he is best known for his film's
crank and Crank 2 high voltage with
Jason Statham the current working title
of the new Hellboy film is Hellboy the
Crooked Man a comic of the same name was
published in 2011 the plot of which
takes place in 1956 where Hellboy meets
Tom a man who sold his soul to a demon
together they travel to the Appalachian
Mountains to confront the demon and save
Tom's Soul how much of the story will be
adapted for the film is unclear as of
yet shooting is scheduled to start in
Bulgaria in April of 2023 and the
casting process has already begun of
course there is the big question of who
will play the Diabolical hero after Ron
Perlman and David Harbor discussing film
reports that they are likely looking for
an actor in his 20s or 30s the film is
expected to be another reboot so whether
in which of the well-known supporting
characters will be in at this time
remains to be seen since the project is
already in production we anticipate more
news very soon there is currently no
release date nor a publisher which means
that a direct release from a streaming
provider is not out of the question we
will keep you up to date as always
the Lord of the Rings trilogy by Peter
Jackson is to this day one of the
biggest film franchises known across
generations and still enjoyed by many
Amazon also acknowledged this a few
years ago when it secured the rights for
its own series set in the second age of
Middle Earth however the series was not
as successful with fans as those in
charge had hoped and in terms of
popularity in particular it falls short
of the movie trilogy from the 2000s by a
long way now as has been reported by
variety there are big plans from Warner
Brothers for new feature films based on
the Lord of the Rings Universe at the
time the movie studio was responsible
for the production of both the Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit trilogy during
the presentation of Warner's quarterly
figures there was the surprising news
that the company will work together with
the embracer group on new movies in the
future Last Summer the embracer group
secured Middle Earth Enterprises meaning
the complete film and Merchandising
rights for the franchise they are now
cooperating with Warner Brothers in a
multi-year deal by the way there should
be no no conflicts in terms of story
with the ongoing Amazon series since it
is set in the second age and according
to reports the upcoming films will again
focus on the third age as announced by
the new heads of the Warner Brothers
film group Michael Deluca and Pamela
Abdi there are still many stories to be
explored in the gigantic Universe of The
Lord of the Rings Creator J.R.R Tolkien
and they would like to immerse
themselves deeper into the world of
Middle Earth along with the fans we are
definitely excited and look forward to
more news from the upcoming the Lord of
the Rings series of movies however it
will certainly take a few more years
until the first movie releases
it was hardly surprising that a third
part of the successful series with Tom
Hardy was announced after the release of
Venom Let There Be Carnage there really
wasn't much info in the past year and a
half so an update on the production was
anxiously awaited by fans via Instagram
Venom star Tom Hardy has now shed some
light on the matter and officially
announced that the movie is still in
pre-production shooting has yet to start
but apparently the cast and script has
been set and filming can be expected to
begin shortly the popularity of Eddie
Brock and his symbiote friend has
increased immensely since the first film
from 2018 which is also reflected in the
box office takings of a total of 1.36
billion US dollars for parts one and two
of Venom the biggest fan desire at the
moment might be to see a clash between
the anti-hero Venom and the superhero
Spider-Man the fueled by Venom's
appearance at the end of Spider-Man no
way home and is absolutely possible due
to Sony's valuable Spider-Man film
rights moreover it should be in the best
interests of all parties concerned to
get the franchise back on track to the
success of the first part with a big hit
after Venom Let There Be Carnage
performed worse than the original in
part also due to the pandemic a release
date is not available yet but we expect
filming to begin this year
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania the
first movie from Phase 5 of the MCU has
recently hit theaters so far the reviews
have been mixed even if the movie was
not as badly received by audiences as it
was by movie critics now that it has
been clear for a few days that Robert
Downey Jr will not return as Iron Man
despite popular fan demand there is the
question of who will be the new leader
of the diverse Superhero Squad if
current rumors are to be believed there
may soon be a superhero following in
Iron Man's footsteps who would not
initially be thought capable of doing so
we are talking about Spider-Man who was
Tony Stark's Protege and shared a
touching father-son relationship with
him after an upcoming Spider-Man 4 was
officially announced recently and Tom
Holland was allegedly cast for a total
of two new films it would make perfect
sense to give the superhero more
responsibility this is also consistent
with the fact that Sony and Marvel
probably want more characters from the
Spider-Man universe to appear in the
upcoming film and fewer superhero Pals
from The Avengers
besides Spider-Man 4 Peter Parker is
also expected to start in the upcoming
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and Lead The
Avengers in the fight against Kang but
first fans can look forward to Tom
Holland's next solo Adventure however
there is sadly no release date for
Spider-Man 4 yet
the MCU is known for producing many
movies in series in an impressively
short time this does not always work out
smoothly in the recent past it often
happened that Marvel had to postpone the
one or other film sometimes by several
months or even years via Twitter Marvel
Studios got in touch last week to reveal
the postponement of one of the upcoming
MCU films the film in question is the
Marvels unofficially known as Captain
Marvel 2. in spite of the release of a
new poster showing the three main
characters the simultaneously announced
postponement comes as a surprise
especially since no official explanation
has been provided by Marvel as to why it
has been pushed back from July to
November 2023 however it is considered
likely that difficulties in
post-production are the cause for the
delay of the theatrical release moreover
it helps to balance Marvel's ambitious
schedule which still includes Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 Spider-Man across
the spider-verse Craven the Hunter and
Loki season 2. the release Ace of the
Marvels thus frees up some time in the
summer and brings 2023 to a proper close
with the film in terms of Story the
movie revolves around the reunion of
three well-known characters Carol
Danvers AKA Captain Marvel Kamala Khan
aka Miss Marvel and Monica Rambo who was
already known from Wanda Vision Khan and
Rambo have their very own history with
the mighty superheroine who has
previously made a solo appearance in the
MCU also the movie picks up where the
MCU series Miss Marvel left off which
came out last year it'll get to the
bottom of why characters suddenly change
locations when using superpowers in
addition to Brie Larson Iman vimani and
Tayana Paris the movie will see The
Return of Samuel L Jackson as Nick Fury
after connections to the Marvels will
also be made in this Summer's MCU series
secret Invasion the movie is scheduled
for release on November 10 2023.
a film about the French military General
Napoleon has been in the works for
several years under the supervision of
director Ridley Scott lead actor Joaquin
Phoenix will portray Napoleon Bonaparte
and the content will be about his rise
to power as well as his relationship
with Empress Josephine as we know since
the last Berlin International Film
Festival this will not be the only
project that focuses on the life of the
general and dictator as Steven Spielberg
revealed on the occasion of the film
festival he has been working on a
Napoleon series for 10 years this was
originally planned by the late cult
director Stanley Kubrick in the 1980s
who had already written the screenplay
back then however the historical film
Waterloo flopped at the time which
failed to win over audiences with a
similar theme as a result Kubrick was
unable to find a studio willing to
accept his project Kubrick eventually
passed away in 1999 at the age of 71
without ever having produced his
Napoleon film together with Kubrick's
Widow Christian and his brother-in-law
Jan Harlan Spielberg to have been
working on a Napoleon series for over 10
years which will be based on the script
originally written for the film The
Project is to be produced for HBO and
will presumably be directed by Spielberg
in an executive role in the past
Spielberg already handled a different
Kubrick project namely the film AI
artificial intelligence further
information is not yet available but it
will surely take some time before the
seven part series can be seen on HBO Max
prior to that we can expect to see
Ridley Scott's Napoleon in theaters
which has already been shot but has not
been given a release date yet
all right now you're back up to date you
can find even more information about the
upcoming Aquaman and the lost kingdom in
our new Original Episode check it out if
you want to learn more about the
upcoming movies characters production
and plot thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]
thank you